back to school for boris johnson
on a visit to south london to promote
schools in england
reopening on march the 8th and now it's
back to school in the summer holidays
for thousands of children in catch-up
classes to help pupils make up
for lost learning due to the pandemic
the government is to spend 700 million
pounds
on tutoring for children who've fallen
behind academically
bringing in freelance tutors or paying
staff to stay behind
to help struggling pupils
the prime minister says this extensive
programme of catch-up funding
will equip teachers with the tools and
resources they need
to support their pupils and give
children the opportunities they deserve
to learn and fulfill their potential
but the response to catch-up classes
from head teachers
is cautious we need money to do these
kind of things if children need
very small group work or one-to-one i
know most schools including me as a head
teacher i want
my own staff to do that i don't want to
buy in people
um because we're a very vulnerable stage
for children coming back into school
safeguarding is absolutely top priority
so
um to do smaller groups with your own
members of staff would mean them working
longer hours working different hours
so i hope that's enough to make a
difference unveiling his four steps to
freedom this week
the prime minister said pupils and
students can safely return to
face-to-face teaching
but some scientists claim his first step
of reopening all schools on march the
8th
could threaten the next steps on the
road out of lockdown
opening schools all at one go seems
quite a big risk since that could put
push up infections quite a lot and and
many people have said it will push
the r rate above one in scotland it's
softly softly and careful so schools are
going to be reopened
in three or four stages uh monitoring
carefully so
so again how cautious it is uh is a
matter of opinion
but the prime minister and says all the
evidence shows
that classrooms are the very best places
for young people to be john craig sky
news